yeah
[Music]
welcome to the eviction
2022.
over the next few weeks you're going to
have a series of very intense property
investment challenges and the winner is
going to be given 20 000 pounds cash
prize to help kick-start your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets evicted
because you needed to be spoon-fed wow
just don't lie to me don't call me a
liar I'm not gonna lie down and take it
can I have a break
about the Coronation Street isn't it
you're evicted
[Music]
welcome to the eviction
2022 over the next few weeks you're
going to be given some really hard
grueling tasks and challenges around
property investment because I want to
see Who's got what it takes to become a
very successful property entrepreneur
the winner is going to receive a cash
prize of 20 000 pounds which you can use
towards kickstarting your property
investment Journey
with the help of various mentors that
are going to be assisting me throughout
these challenges I'll decide who stays
and who gets
evicted
challenge is going to be in this
property now this property needs to go
to market and your first challenge is
going to be to stage and furnish the
property now a lot of average people
would spend two to three weeks and they
might spend 20 30 000 pounds Furnishing
a property like this to make it look
good but you're not supposed to be
average I want to see you using your
skills to get this done quickly and to
get this done cost effectively
you're gonna have two days and you're
gonna have six thousand pounds in total
to furnish the property you're gonna be
in two teams
so you're gonna have three thousand
pounds each team one will be Diamante
Nicholas
Adriana
Scott
and Adam
team two will be Isabella Ricky Jody
shirelle and Matt Team One You're Gonna
Be Furnishing the kitchen the living
room and the two front bedrooms
team two you're going to be Furnishing
the dining room the upstairs living area
and the two back bedrooms
so once you leave this boardroom I would
suggest that you select a team leader
and get started pretty quick because in
48 hours two of you from the losing team
will be evicted here's your money
good luck I'll see you in 40 hours
so what's everyone thinking team
leader-wise you've got the most
experience yeah yeah I I have experience
I am a professional artist I am good at
Art and Design my name is dimante and
Siena I did 20 years fashion design but
now I started Interiors so I'm interior
designer beginner
um I just saw few YouTubes and also my
partner and my family members visit like
look this is something what you would
like to do and I said really uh I'm not
sure I always want to be an architect
actually and why not let's try let's go
and it was just amazing like after a few
courses I realized like this is what I
love to do all opinions in don't be shy
we can discuss we can argue we can do
anything you know
in a team work I help people find more
ideas together we can organize who is
doing what you know and you you can tell
me what you good at as well I'm good at
learning negotiating and we need to
haggoke to obviously get the price down
on things I've got a project management
background a kind of structure in terms
of planning what we need to kind of do I
think my skills will learn creativity
and bringing us a whole sort of vision
of the project together I'm a Tradesman
I've been in multi-million pound homes
so I know what they look like this is an
expensive home so I'm pretty sure on how
to dress it so we've got two huge
project management who's gonna be the
leader yeah I can delete it
yeah we have it sometimes they said I'm
crazy
[Music]
well so we need to figure out between as
a team leader I need to figure out who's
got experience in interior design yep
you have a furnished place before yeah
I've done interior design in my own
essays before yep same
cool so it feels confident enough to
head up the team then in this one I feel
really confident so Jordan I'll go Jody
okay yeah
Phil I'm very much alone in the property
world and I thought being around other
people with the same passion and the
same path that I want to go down I just
thought it'd really really helped me
being around these people I am
open-minded and I like to take on
everyone's views and we'll put them
together and then come up with the best
idea so I think first things first we
will need to get a list on price
everything we can because I think the
cheaper we go the better so if we're
under budget I think that's going to be
a winner I think when we do the list of
what things that we need we should maybe
choose which things need to be a bit
more quality so when people are here
they still get that luxury feel
I am quite impatient when it comes to
business so if people did dandel in
talking a lot I'm like look if we've
done a deal we've done that deal close
off go to the next one so I think first
things first is take a look at the rooms
and then we'll just need to start
figuring out where we're shopping first
things first is look at the rooms and
we'll go from there yeah
exciting
should we use the table which is what
I'm thinking yeah let's take the table
we'll be allowed to use that table was
it a Samuel's table we don't get a lot
of work for us well we'll have two
people on each corner there we go we'll
go backwards
they're already nicking the table out
the other room so let's have a look
around yeah what about the rugs take the
rugs oh this is nice in the living room
we just stole it
what else can we roll okay we need to
look for sofas and beds we just need to
get to the town center and start looking
it let's do this
I'll probably get some Ziploc beds I'm
looking for some deliveries tomorrow I
wonder if you had it in stock the
delivery date would have to be tomorrow
it'll really push the time on this
[Music]
oh you're not gonna be able to get
through them buildings there though if
you definitely got it yeah yeah I've got
it
you want to go around
you're gonna be walking through a shop
that might have an entrance at back
these maps are not working yet hold on
okay we need to go back that way oh
bloody Maps my name is Ricky so what
makes me different to everybody else on
the eviction is the fact that I'm quite
young I'm only 20 years old even though
I might be the youngest I know for a
fact that I equally stand a chance just
as much as everybody else I think we're
supposed to come up this way dude I'm
sure we can go through here man is it
upstairs yeah I think so maybe what's
the store called sleep eight sleep what
sleep eight sleep eight look
so what we're going to do visualize
sleeping
good good one
if we can't find any beds we'll just
give them virtual beds
literally 0.7 miles away from here wait
hold on is it all
right let's not water 20 minutes walk
give me the address hahaha
oh my God you're running up as well I
was just about to say this big white
sofa sit in it it feels quite
comfortable take a seat and it's large
isn't it so right now we've come into
the British heart foundation on the
lookout for zipling beds what we've
actually found is an amazing large sofa
sat in it and it feels absolutely luxury
and what feels really good is because
we're in the British Heart Foundation
our spy in here is helping the community
around here as well and we're getting
what we need like win-win so how much is
this sorry 350 quid 350 pounds shall we
get it I reckon get it and then what's
the likelihood of the delivery is it
still up in the air we don't know yeah
okay oh drugstore covered so we can't
sit about today so about tomorrow uh
tomorrow we're looking at getting
another van in but I can't promise you
what can we do to kind of get like
certainty to get certainty High your own
van games yeah it will happen normally
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
sets of chairs for the bedrooms a garden
set which I'm carrying here we've got
some small items to kind of furniture
property as well so really excited and
on to the next door
so we're looking around at different
charity shops we're trying to find the
sofas and beds the biggest thing that's
going to be into our budget we're going
to look over at home since and go to our
Ikea as well and then we'll make a
decision based on that then after
we've got a sofa no way yeah look at
this so they can deliver it tomorrow's
brand new Factory sealed no and then
they've also got the single lot beds for
four beds 500 but I think we can
negotiate for a bundle
so looking for a sofa I went on to
Facebook Marketplace message the guy and
he's going to do it for 560 which is
half the price of what they wanted it
for in the store so that's getting
delivered tomorrow which will mean we're
in time for the deadline and we've got
beds as well they've thrown to beds in
so then we're going to negotiate as well
[Music]
oh no what is it my tile popped I can't
get back so I need help I am so happy I
have men I have a woman I have a brains
let's go to do it because I can't get
back you got a spare tire no you don't
no tire
you need a new tire totally
you curved it all on the side
oh
so popular I did it yeah you got a AI or
anything eight but like an hour and a
half wait yeah yeah how far is it I came
from here
15 minutes at most
I have a emergency problem with my Volvo
I am near the London my tire popped and
I need emergency help please
can we try them out yeah
oh this is comfy it's got a good spring
in it or any of these zip lock then or
the older singles by themselves it
specifically has to be Ziplocs yeah you
get two separate mattresses right no
it's gonna be one
mattresses we need two symbols
that might be that's not gonna work what
we need right I know what you say the
base is clear we put them together but
the mattress has to be the same so I
need to be able to have a couple or two
separate people that's what that's what
a zip bed is it's two mattresses that
just zip together
thought we're on to it then
thought we're on to it then I know I
just really want the zip beds because
that's the single doesn't work we're
pushing them together because you don't
middle of them
guys come back he will do a zip bed for
us how much I don't know
[Music]
[Applause]
and the obviously will just start to
plan there what we're going to do so
shall we leave day here shall we not
um so we're going to leave deer we're
hiring a van from Ikea yeah put a
spanner in the works but we've worked
around it and we're back on track and
like nurse you like Echo
we came to this store and we couldn't
find the ZIP beds the the men had just
two single beds which was really helpful
however we focused on zip beds and it
takes time you need to order them I
start to speak to the men and he said
well he might be able to help us well
two minutes later he said good news I
can help you so let's just clarify you
want to give us two zip link beds
delivered tomorrow so what we're talking
money-wise
okay
and the verdict is doesn't look like a
happy face
I feel like there should be a handshake
going on right now
come on
face
wow it's been a fantastic day we've been
splitting to two teams to furnish this
amazing Barn conversion and we've
ordered the beds that come in tomorrow
we order the nice lovely sofa that's
coming tomorrow we had some hiccups on
the way as well one of our teammates had
a flat tire so that's kind of set us
back a little bit so my tire is still
popped I just need the help I just need
actually somebody to pick up me because
all my belongings in the car never had
this adventure before
foreign
we're just going to try and get the
final bits for the two bedrooms so I
think we've had a really productive day
and everyone's getting involved as well
there's not really anyone who's we're
carrying this like sort of thing so far
anyway a bit of tiredness kicks in
tonight a bit of lack of sleep you might
find out tomorrow but a bit of a weak
links in team but we don't know that yet
what do you reckon 582 582
[Applause]
because you got me Northern
lift it
lift it
[Music]
successfully we managed to get the beds
we're getting that delivered tomorrow we
got the dining table that is free
because we just got that straight
straight from one of the other rooms
we're going to have a late night tonight
yeah because we need to get the
wardrobes we need to get everything set
up and ready tonight yeah from just
sleep on the floor I think everyone's
going to do whatever they can to win the
test
I'm confident for my team that we're
going to win a smash it at the park so I
think we've got another couple hours yet
so it's gonna be a late night
foreign
[Music]
rather comfortable for probably a
maximum of three hours so I didn't
really matter that much we was up till
4am this morning fit in the wardrobes so
we're absolutely shattered
super snore here he starts kicking off
straight away like a baby so me and
Scott are like okay that's that then
some of us slept better than others
I think the mentors are going to be
impressed with some of our pieces I
think especially these chairs so these
are actually from a charity shop the
vibrant the colorful I know both mentors
are interior designers so I think
they're going to be quite impressed
foreign
[Music]
ER and I am a property Ambassador in
both commercial properties and
Residential Properties so I'm really
expecting to come in there and feel a
flow when you first walk into the house
you want some kind of presentation to
welcome you into the space I mean
they've got enough time to create
something luxurious and I get super
offended if it's not done right
[Music]
so do you want to show me around what
you've done yeah definitely so this
thing's still to arrive
I mean I do feel with the amount of view
that there is I do feel like you could
have done a lot more
just trying to think about me and like
whenever I dress my houses within a
short space of time I could pretty much
get it all done in one day so it would
have been really nice to have come here
and like actually seen more like the
carpets not down it's rolled up over
there I don't feel that there is an
actual flow here
right let's start from the beginning
on a service accommodation I want to see
croissants I want to see buns
big fruit bowl would you like a muffin
would you like a croissant
I don't know what that is but it's
absolutely horrific
I would never have those chairs in here
ever it's a crime
I would have had a beautiful Diamond
table right here you put a table right
down here
and what you're doing again is you're
framing the view think of LA
honey the table goes here
that is an insult it just shows it's
fast
it's it's it's an insult
make magic happen
what are you waiting for run
now
let's go I was super underwhelmed I
definitely was expecting a lot more done
considering they had pretty much had 24
hours to at least make it look
presentable but I just saw a lot of
sparsed plants and that was pretty much
it
wow you've just got totally grilled by
jail you're gonna stand there and take
it you know you realize that oh actually
yeah we're doing some stuff wrong but
that's why we're here you know we're
here to learn I think we took all that
on board I think with three people they
could have done a lot better with the
budget that they have just five people
even worse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I thought I'd call on a team meeting
this morning because our main thing
that's going to be hard to get chairs to
go around the table yesterday I didn't
really know the team that well but today
I do so that is what I've allocated what
are the names
I've allocated shirelle Isabelle and
Ricky to do that because cherelle is
really really good at negotiating so
I've told her to go to charity shops
because we're on a tight budget now like
Jody said herself you know yesterday I
was just kind of seeing what everyone's
doing today she put some things in place
so this is where we're going to see you
know how it's going to kind of go
because everyone's got a vision whose
vision's gonna Trump
where are you guys I'm in High Wycombe
you're in high Wicket so what have you
got at the moment
we haven't got anything
yeah
who's gone Ikea Ricky go in Ikea I just
thought that was our last last Last
Resort that is just us bailing out too
soon and getting what we want
no no no I was just ringing because me
and Matt we've pretty much nearly got
everything we need so we're here to help
that's not the tone you're giving me on
the phone you've kind of said you don't
understand why we're giving up you
haven't
no because I didn't understand why it
was 12 o'clock and you decided like
giving up means you're going to Ikea at
12 o'clock when we could go there at 9pm
tonight so what do you
up back at the house because we've got a
visitor and then we go from there now
preferably
[Laughter]
I'm Amanda Leeds and I've had lots of
experience with interior design I
actually used to have a company that
used to stage and furnish properties so
I'm really excited to see what the team
is going to do with this Barn because
it's like the perfect blank canvas to
just go crazy at and see how creative
they can be hello
fill me in fill me in we're doing well
we're on budget so do you feel like
everyone's pulling their weight as team
leader like
yeah I think we're pulling away I think
everyone else is pulling their weight
and everyone's coming together as a team
really well
show me what your plans are for each of
the rooms it's going to be like green
jungle Vibes because it makes it calm
it's like being at one with nature yeah
so we've got this to go in their
wardrobe because if that goes on there
like that uh okay
yeah and you're on budget yeah I'm
really surprised actually because it's
quite good you've managed to get
wardrobes and which which is your other
space is it upstairs that Landing
upstairs yeah we haven't really done
so yourself for delivery's coming today
they've promised yeah okay Samuel I
think was thinking of having maybe
that's like a nice lounging area but
also maybe yeah we tried to get a pool
table with this table what about a
dartboard
did you also have the dining room as
well yeah should we go and have a look
at what you've done there we didn't want
these chairs but we're struggling to
find ones that match this that table
that they've got in the dining room is
actually the boardroom tables that's not
going to go down well with Samuel when
he turns up and he's going to be sat at
his table and he's not going to be a
table there so I don't know what they're
thinking to do and to rectify that for
Samuel but that's going to be really
interesting to see how he reacts to that
so you'd mentioned that you'd kind of
gone off Vision even though going off
Vision it's not a thing that we went far
away you know the world isn't always
there just at your feet just saying
you're thinking of that here it is and
then we're managing time and stuff as
well well my biggest tip would be
continue communicating if you need help
like say you need help you can all stand
strong when you're in the boardroom
think that they're doing quite well
because the budget's not massive for
such a big house they've ordered all the
big items which can usually take a while
to be delivered so they seem to be on
the money
bit of an urgent matter our delivery
driver is canceled on us today and we
urgently need to pick our sofa up have
you got a van available that we can have
just for like two hours maximum
Way by Wickham oh Christ now we're miles
away
huh I'm just in a bit of a pickle at the
moment um one of my delivery drivers
canceled on me I literally need to hire
a van for maybe a couple of hours is
that possible
um
as you know who spoke to you earlier
guys we handed a real life lesson by
jail so we needed more so we didn't
really budget for a dining room table so
we thought how can we be creative and
kind of get this for the best possible
price and we care about options donate
some money to charity and we can loan
this table furniture from you guys for
40 hours we'll bring it back good Nick
we'll take care of it at proper donate
to charity so that wasn't kind of the
option that we came up with at least
option on the furniture table foreign
pick up the sofas from the British Art
Foundation charity shop and he said
that's gonna be not a problem whatsoever
so I just pulled this out of the site
we're getting a bit pressed for time now
because I mean the beds aren't here yet
so all the beds need making up the
softening is putting in place if they do
get a pool table or a hockey table that
is setting up and taking up up to the
other living room up there so we're a
bit pressed for time really
so zero wallpaper and experience them
bits that I've just put up there first
ever bits I've ever put up so look at
all the monkey jumper box up on there
looks good does Samuel like monkeys
couldn't tell you it's quite a cheeky
guy
[Music]
thank you
so the first one guys come straight
through number two to the other room
[Music]
look at the zips
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
that is on the drill
where's my teeth
it's so nice come on three minutes
[Music]
thank you
yeah
[Music]
good to be back
what's up what's going on in there then
where's the um where's my table
Bear yeah but this is this is this is my
room
I hope they're not taking my table
okay so this looks quite nice it is
isn't it that's my table
I've taken my boardroom table that's not
on is it it does look nice in here
are you talking about this table
I guess you'll have to speak to them
about that
what do you think of the sofa I think
they've done well to get this comfy
it sounds like a pretty good quality
soap for this Jail's team managed to get
a sofa and a table your team stole my
table we haven't seen what my team's
done yet so maybe we should just have a
look around let's have a look up here
what on Earth is that
this is your team
I'm quite underwhelmed
oh
nice
I mean this is like Airbnb ready they've
done everything that I've literally said
with the budget
so I'm actually pretty impressed I'm
trying to find what to criticize really
oh God no
why why did they pick these chairs
that is absolutely terrible
I wouldn't put this in the kids room
I envisioned something do you envisioned
something good yeah this is from a
charity shop and it's obvious it doesn't
live up to the expectation of the rest
of the house you've got a very strange
old looking whatever that is hockey ice
thing the other team got a good sofa and
got their own table well let's see the
bedrooms because maybe in the bedrooms
it looks amazing and it has to be
amazing to balance it out yeah
wow oh this is good yeah it did really
well oh wow I mean are these zip beds
yes they are oh that's now look so they
can be separated if needed brilliant so
this could be a twin room it can be a
double room it's a small wardrobe it
looks perfect
10 out of 10. oh God what is that I mean
I know they've tried but that is not
going to come up on a picture at all if
I was coming to stay in a guest room I
would not
want to see pictures on the floor
I think it's cool and with the animals
on the print there as well I think it's
just a bit different a bit quirky
I don't like the monkeys at all
I'm not feeling it what in God's name
what what is that is that supposed to be
a piece of art
that's I mean that looks like someone
literally ran out of wallpaper and just
stuck
that's terrible
oh my God
oh my God
is this actually hiding this
I'm so sorry that is terrible if I was
coming to a service accommodation I was
going to be renting out a room I
certainly wouldn't want to have pieces
of paper hanging off the walls
it's not okay
foreign
a bit awkward really because I've not
got my table so
I mean
could you get it for me because it's my
table so
we'll just wait awkwardly
thank you thank you
brilliant
[Music]
so the house looks very different you're
three thousand miles each did you spend
all the money do you have any any change
pounds we got pounds left oh wow do you
want to give it to me then
ultimately the house is furnished
overall it looks good you were
responsible for half of the house you're
responsible for the half of the house we
said that there's guests coming and
there are and the guests who are going
to be staying in this house for the next
few weeks are going to be you guys
you're the guest however unfortunately
two people will be evicted and that will
be two people from the losing team in
terms of who the losing team is Amanda
what are your thoughts when I came you
guys had ordered your big ticket items
and you'll see You'd started putting the
rugs up for the headboards so it was
looking really really good I do think
that the bedrooms look nice but that
room upstairs the games room I found it
a bit underwhelming I think there's a
few problems there's a few things I
didn't like obviously the boardroom
table but also didn't like the sofa
didn't like the ice hockey table I get
what you were going for we wanted a pool
table that would have been better I know
but we could he let us down last how
much did you pay for the ice rocket
table 350 pounds 350 pounds I was more
concerned about this team to be
perfectly honest because when I spoke to
JL JL was just like they're not doing
anything they've got no vision so when I
first went in I was horrified to see
there was absolutely nothing coming back
today
very impressed
I do believe that you guys took
literally everything I said and ran with
it and I'm super impressed with that
who was your team leader me how did you
leave the team day I let him do uh what
we let them how did you lead them I
wasn't like I am a boss I am designer
everything should be what I want apart
from letting them do what they wanted
how did you lead them
but talk to me about the painting in the
room to be fair that was Dee's idea so
so there we go that's how you led I love
that painting and I was wondering I
thought did they buy this and just sign
it but it looks really good
old Team all Team D who was the weak
Link in your team the worst person
it's very difficult question so what's
the answer
I have no answer Nick who is the weakest
link from a project management
perspective if I was judging it I would
say we weren't really LED as a PM and
obviously D had a hiccup of a car as
well so she was out of the game for half
of the first day so just some of the
technicality I'll probably say that
what about Jody who is the weak link on
your team I would say Ricky is the
weakest link on my team because a number
of tasks I asked him to do he didn't
want to do because he didn't want to get
his suit dirty or he didn't want to take
his suit off at no point do I care about
getting my suit day that has never been
an issue yes I kept it on but there's no
issue with me keeping it on when I asked
you to paint the frames you said no I'm
not doing that I'll get dirty
I'm not taking my suit off and I said
okay then I will and I said if you like
cleaning so much go and pick up a Hoover
and clean you went no I need to sort out
my car first because I've spilled
coconut what did Matt say he said what
do you care about winning this challenge
or caring about your car I helped with
so much I put majority of the furniture
together if anything Eula was giving up
on the furniture thing or I can't do
this
she's put together we've got three
chairs together I've got all the chairs
I put the wardrobes into her together
you can ask her else before we say you
lot my view on this will be yes Ricky
you did contribute but you did need
guidance because you're not been in this
experience before so yes you did need
guidance coming through if I was the
furniture goals that wasn't unfortunate
wasn't majority you didn't do majority
but yes you did put the chairs together
and I know that you've made Milestone
milestones for yourself which is amazing
but as a group in its entirety the
initiative like what we spoke about that
was not your strong point no
Joe are you a team leader of the whole
team yes did you think you did a good
job of being with the whole team and
leading them yeah I do what do you think
Sharelle what do you think how do you
think Jody did so there's definitely
room for improvement there was
definitely a hurdle that we had to jump
because there was a bit of
um misdirection at the beginning and
there was a bit of a clash because of
that I think I can't say I was super
happy when I walked into my boardroom
was was gone I mean your team leader Joe
day how did that happen well we only had
a budget of 3 000 pounds so to save
money we saw the table and we thought it
would be the smartest decision to take
it did you think about taking the lights
and stuff as well no oh yeah we did wow
just take me as well
all right crazy
so I think Jody's team I think did
really well you know you had two days
you had three thousand pounds I think
you did well
but I think Dee's team were flawless
this is the winning team
he's staying in the house so thank you
so much off you go
[Music]
so guys unfortunately you are on the
losing team we've only got eight
bedrooms and there's ten of us in total
so two of you will have to be evicted so
why shouldn't you be evicted today sure
I shouldn't be evicted because as a team
member I can bring so much value for
negotiations for communications and also
once I get to the point of being a
project leader and should that happen
I'll be able to help bring the team
together as well so everyone can use
their strengths Ricky I actually told
these that this challenge would
definitely be my weakest point because
my strong points lie in talking to
people negotiating with people selling
deals Jody why should you not be
addicted I shouldn't be evicted because
I think I played a really good role in
this team I chose most of the
decorations here uh the headboards
um the wardrobes I made sure that
everything was done everything was done
on time is it better why should you not
be evicted I shouldn't be evicted
because I've got very friendly
personality so you shouldn't be evicted
because you're friendly isn't it Matt
why should you not be evicted I
shouldn't be a victory because I
generally feel that I will one one of if
not the strongest person in this team on
this on this task and this is nowhere
near my bread and butter sure how do you
think he was one of the strongest
contestants Matt was definitely
um you know he definitely brought stuff
okay Matt you're good you're safe so
you're off you go
[Music]
so shirelle do you think you were a
better contestant than Jojo I do think I
was a better contestant to Jody because
as the leader it doesn't matter New or
Old you need to take direction
if I finish that would be amazing so the
task that me Isabella and Ricky was
given on the second day was to go to
round to loads of Charity shops to try
and find the um headboards for the bed
the headboards the canvas and the chairs
around the table and the chairs around
the table I noticed that she was really
good at negotiate exactly so if I could
explain that go out there and get
everything myself just to make wow so
the bottom line was at the morning when
you finally woke up and said you decided
to now manage to sleep I was up all
night
that you did not leave Ricky who was
stronger cherelle or Jonah I definitely
feel sure I was Stronger
All right sure you're safe thank you
[Music]
why do you think Jody that everybody in
the team
thought that shirelle was stronger than
you she's a very very bold character I'm
not going to dim Her Shine just because
she's a bold character I'm going to let
her speak I want everyone's opinions in
the team I'm not going to be like no
you'd be quiet I'm the team leader I
make the decision ultimately you didn't
lead I was having to go to Cheryl for
the next time
who should be evicted I reckon Jody
should be evicted for not leading very
well I definitely difficult constantly
feel like shirelle was the one that's
leading it's because you needed to be
spoon-fed you can't spoon feed it's not
everyone on your teeth you got to give
instructions
how many times did we have to tell you
you're not tired no no that's because
the aisle was a working properly it's a
different type of iron
Isabella do you think Ricky was a strong
contestant
not on this challenge not on this
challenge
Ricky I'm really sorry on this occasion
you're evicted
[Music]
Joe deck why should Isabella be a victim
instead of you
visual Myers and having an input into
the
desires Cheryl not by you
Isabella's lovely but I think you kind
of need to be a bit have that tenacity
that Jody has I think that you know you
don't listen to your team I think you're
not listening to me you're talking about
something you know and I think that as a
businesswoman you shouldn't be over
talking people don't I'm talking sorry
no I don't know I wasn't there but you
make a lot of noise
and I don't know if you're producing as
much as you're making I think Jody's
either gonna
annoy the hell out of everybody or she
could end up
doing extremely well Isabella has got a
lot about her
but unfortunately I think on this
occasion
Isabella you're evicted
[Applause]
I feel sad we didn't
put yeah I couldn't protect myself
I'm feeling very disappointed I
definitely don't think I should have
been the one to go I definitely feel
like Jody should have been the one to go
since she didn't really lead as a leader
I don't think I was the right person
dictator
's ability to think about it out because
I didn't really catch her doing much to
be fair
the person who should win eviction is
Cheryl I definitely think that shirelle
should be the one to win she's really
strong beautiful personality and really
focused foreign
it was hard work but also it was a life
lesson the experience was really good
it's made me think differently about how
I can use my time it's going to be the
reason why I'm going to have a much
stronger work ethic
[Music]
[Music]
I just gotta do this on a regular
occurrence I'll be absolutely minted on
Yachts soon
[Music]
[Applause]
what's the weird I've just told you
what's up don't call me a likes I'm not
a liar I'm just telling you I've not
caused a stir it right
a bit of shambles I don't disappointed
with you I think it's going to be close
you're addictive
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]